here's another thing a lady said on
Twitter that I say you know what I mean
a lot you do I know so from now on
whenever I say it you have to say it
stop why it's just the way you talk I
know I don't want to do it anymore and
I've been caught I've been conscious
what I'm stopped no I'm stopping
I use a lot of fluff words we're not
professional broad you know I I want to
be they want you to be like exact with
your words he just says you know what I
mean F a lot a lot every thought and so
I have not said it that was the first
time I said that Oh everybody has that
though yeah you don't have it I always
say sort of sort of well I stopped by
you say you feel me a lot yeah that's so
that's why I'm trying to be conscious of
it because I don't want to do anymore
it's it's it's it's a it's cheating yeah
because you're trying to think of the
next line it's it's repetitive and when
you hone in on it when somebody has like
you know I mean I even realize it how'd
you even catch it I didn't even hear so
normal I know I people here I also just
like tuna mod regularly so that's it
what are we doing at all oh wait did you
guys watch you did I know did you watch
the new Dave Chappelle's special yes I
did yeah me too I don't know how anyone
I also I'm kind of little biased because
I think Dave Chappelle can do no wrong I
can't be objective about anything Dave
Chappelle because I just think that the
[ __ ] Sun shines on his ass I think
he's so funny he hasn't lost I think it
was the deep in the heart of Texas
wasn't as refined you know the age of
spin was really good oh for sure yeah
but it was like recorded two years ago
yeah that's so like the jokes are a
little more dated like he was still
talking about like Donald sterling and
things that weren't as like relevant
today but I didn't think he missed a
beat anyway people didn't like it um I
was reading a review I think it was on
variety or Fox I don't remember but it
was really critical it was like yeah it
was good
but it wasn't or the hope he got a lot
of heat from the LGBTQ could give heat
to everybody though somebody got some
heat from them and also just stop adding
[ __ ] to it but that's his joke lgp was
like what the [ __ ] is cute yeah that's a
joke he was talking about he was like he
that's okay so he was going into how
basically saying like how gay people and
compare compare their strife to being
black and he was like nope hold up you
can't do that you know we've been you
know we've been struck you know I mean
historically struggling far longer
basically and so that was the gist of it
I thought it was really harmless I think
that we had a really good points about
Filipinos too that I was like yes he's
correct even if it was like politically
incorrect or whatever whatnot he's like
a master Awards he doesn't in a way
where it just it kind of just I don't
get offended by anything that he says
he's very smart with his words yeah so I
thought it I also have never been
offended by any comedian I've ever
watched in my lifetime median you know
that's a different generation now though
like if you read YouTube comments they
get offended by everything
if you step into a comedy club like this
you run the [ __ ] out you know I mean so
yeah I had a we had an interesting
discussion earlier today why are you
serving it that's good you're being so
straight I'm feeling weird I don't want
to keep talking no you talk I want to
know okay you just hear the breathing
okay listening to them talk I hear Bunco
yeah yeah okay no I'm not vibing it
[Music]